[Applause]
hello here's what's coming up for you on
this week's white the Masters of modding
we meet the experts will tell you how to
make your PC gaming Beast then discover
the games that are looked most
captivating on your newly souped-up
machine and we'll finish with playing of
a different color inside one of the most
famous recording studios in the world
welcome to swipe from Abbey Road Studios
in London we're going to be showing you
some of the latest innovations in
digital music making in a few minutes
first though let's get a quick look at
some of this week's tech news headlines
despite a petition signed by more than
1.2 million people changes to snapchat
look set to stay an update separated
content from friends from that of
friends and celebrities something users
said defeated the purpose of the app but
the company has said the features will
adapt to users and they hope the
community will enjoy it once they settle
in researchers at the University of
Bristol have used a tractor beam of
sound waves to move a levitating object
around an obstacle course for the first
time engineers want to be able to
develop the technique to use inside the
human body to remove a kidney stone for
example and ubers boss says he can see
the commercialization of the companies
uber air flying taxis within five to ten
years the firm expects travelling by
flying vehicle to eventually become an
affordable way of getting around
now if you're a gamer you'll know the
importance of brilliant gameplay
graphics is what drives the PC modding
community who are determined to make
those top games you play look even
better this week chris has been meeting
people who spend big on enhancing their
gaming experience it might look like the
engine room of an alien spaceship but
these are in fact the innards of a
high-end gaming PC it's the sort of
machine you might put together if you're
a hardcore gamer it's built from scratch
from hand-picked parts designed to push
graphics to the absolute limits so you
release the pin this workshop aims to
help beginners get into PC modding
there's plenty of advice to get started
stick to 32 maybe 45 percent of your
budget of an entire PC being spent on
the graphics card because the graphics
card is going to be the bit that's going
to make the biggest difference to your
games be make sure you spend a good
amount of money on the Kooning because
if you if you make sure that you get
your cooling correct and your system
will be both cool and quietly don't get
to the point of breaking something I
would say take your time if you're not
sure about something look on YouTube for
videos asks and friends go on a forum
double check before you do it now if
you're a gamer chances are you want the
best graphics possible but how realistic
is it to put something like one of these
together I mean how much is it going to
cost you at the absolute top of the
range people have been known to spend
tens of thousands of pounds on their
setups but pcs like these ones
considered the medium to high-end will
set you back around 2 grand though these
two could be getting more expensive
that's thanks to the rise of crypto
currencies like Bitcoin where people are
building powerful pcs in the hope of
getting rich this machines are just
mining solidly there's a very very minor
percentage of people that we use a
gaming PC to do crypto so that's one of
the reasons why at the moment there's a
graphics card shortages as soon as they
come in the crypto guys are buying them
all up
and that's driving prices up because
people just can't get them at the moment
despite the popularity of consoles pc
gaming is as popular as ever you only
need to look at the ongoing success of
eSports and online communities or
workshops like these are making modding
more accessible but just how hard is it
to build one yourself it could be quite
challenging most people describe it sort
of my adult Legos it's not as difficult
people think they might overthink it
they might think it's too difficult and
then there was a stress over some of the
parts can be rather fiddly and you also
have that kind of burden if you break
one of the parts it's not covered but it
does actually look quite exciting Chris
Creegan Sky News well given all of that
this seems like the perfect opportunity
to dedicate our games review to those
titles that will look most breathtaking
when you play them on a powerful PC
here's ELISA while star wars 2
battlefront may have caused a little bit
of controversy based on how it monetized
one thing is definitely indisputable it
is gorgeous and that's kind of down to
the frostbite engine
frostbite powers everything and it was
created by EA dice and the frostbite
engine is known for a number of things
one of them is that it's able to create
eye watering Li powerful and amazing
animations weather effects and lighting
effects and on PC
all of those are turns up to 11 so it's
definitely the best place to experience
doubles battlefront if you haven't read
[Music]
project cars - is all about the photo
realism so that means when you're
driving one of our hundred and eighty
cars around the track you'll find that
tendrils of water disappear over the
windscreen and
the Sun really gleams off of the bonnet
but if you're on PC you also get the
added benefit of the fact that you can
tweak a bunch of different visual
toggles from heat Hayes's to screamed
there's so much to choose from the real
kicker is that project cars on PC is
incredible due to its virtual reality
technology
nothing beats sitting actually inside a
car in virtual reality and looking
around at some incredible graphics
that's me - isn't the most
photorealistic sheets are on the market
but it's still one of the best-looking
and that's because it's got real
attention to detail honestly I spent at
least a minute staring at these bullet
holes they've been riddled through a
concrete wall because the textures are
so stunning and when you've got all the
power of a really high-end PC graphics
cards those tiny details really burst
into life so shadows the deeper hues of
colors are brighter and it just looks
stunning
hell-blade Sununu sacrifice was one of
these standout games from 2017 and
that's for a number of reasons partly
its treatment of mental health but also
its facial animation tech it is some of
the best you'll find this side of the
uncanny valley there's a lot of scenes
where you're going through rivers or
you're going through really dark caves
or really fierce combats and from scene
to scene everything runs super smoothly
and that's because on PC
how BIG's new his sacrifice runs it's 60
frames per second it just runs buttery
smooth on PC and finally this week let's
make some music all the greats have been
here at Abbey Road over the years the
Beatles
Elton Carney a Taylor swipe first came
here a couple of years ago after Abbey
Road launched its incubator scheme for
music tech startups now I've come back
to check out a few of the latest
innovations coming out of the studios I
changed my life all once or twice lucky
snake eyes on the dies hit the jump I
hit the gold one your heart and one your
soul
indigo palace wrote this song using the
first app to be developed by Abbey Road
Studios it's called top line and it
allows artists to capture lyrics and
music then share them with other band
members instantly so they can add their
own ideas and sounds to the same piece
it means they don't have to wait weeks
until they're together in the same room
to write a song you'll forget stuff all
the time he that was like the main thing
that he used to say when to see Rosa I
had this sick idea and I can't remember
and it was just like this constant
struggling we spent half a session
trying to recreate that initial spot so
I've just sent D this track and his and
then he's put it in to this section and
then he can record and add his bits over
it the verse here and then basically you
save it allow and then now I can just
export this although your feelings are
secondary
hard they're so cold the apps not
perfect though the main thing that I
would like to see is potentially just a
volume control that and also adding a
reverb audio effect Jocelyn tells me
reverb is just the recreation of a room
that you're in add a reverb to it it's
to bring a little bit of life and just
like a space so they're recording it
Abbey Road isn't just developing
technology for new music in the room
next door there's D mixing software that
can make an old song sound much clearer
like this Rolling Stones track from the
60s the technology separates the
different bits of audio so it can reduce
the noise of screaming fans - what we do
is we create think prints of all the
instrumentation that's within the
recording so in the case of the track
air it's harmonica drums guitars and the
program is trained to look out for those
fingerprints within the recording and
when it hears a harmonica that pushes
the audio to the harmonica track the
drum track and so forth like that now
Abbey Road say we're the first members
of the media to film in this room which
is used for creating surround sound
movie tracks it's clear all this
innovating is key for the studio's
strong reputation but I wondered how it
benefits them to develop things like the
free app we saw indigo Parris using we
just want to be very close to the talent
of the future to make sure that they
remember about us that they come to
throw it all a job that they use are in
your facilities they used our new
studios they are engaging they're all
sort of different technological
development
[Music]
well that's it for this week's show
don't forget to join us again next week
for more swipe and in the meantime why
not follow us on twitter at sky news
swipe see you soon bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]